this is a really fast quickly growing
movement
among millennials something like 10
identify as
a third gender so that's a lot of people
and
i would be totally on board with people
identifying however they want if it
didn't also include
things like medical interventions like
double mastectomies
taking testosterone testosterone in a
lot of cases and in a lot of cases
i think these are just young gay people
who
are struggling with that
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report as always guys make sure you're
subscribed to our youtube channel and
have clicked that
pesky notification bell and joining me
today is a neuroscientist who
specializes in gender
sex and sexual orientation as well as
the author
of the new book the end of gender
debunking the myths about
sex and identity in our society dr debra
so welcome back to the reuben report
hi dave thank you for having me again so
i was checking
right before i sat down to see when i
had you on last and it's it's almost two
years to the day it's two years to the
week
and we were talking about much of the
stuff that you wrote about in this book
gender and the whole lgbt
letter conglomeration and identity and
all of these things
and i remember when we sat down for the
first time that a lot of people said oh
no this trans stuff
this isn't real nobody really cares
about this stuff
all these things these are just made up
things that only academics and you
youtubers care about
flash forward two years to where we're
at right now with your book coming out
this weekend it's like
this is one of the biggest issues around
so
i guess my first question is it must
feel pretty good to not be crazy huh
i guess so but i'm just so horrified by
how everything has turned out i mean i
was really
when i saw you two years ago i remember
things were just starting to pick up in
the mainstream
and i was still hoping there's still a
chance maybe this is going to get caught
people are going to figure things out
we're going to
be able to cut this off before it gets
too crazy but it really has just gotten
worse
and with the end of gender i wrote that
book really with the hope of trying to
again
bring more attention to these issues so
that people might take them seriously
and realize that
you know we're not just a bunch of
fringe crazy people complaining about
things these have real
implications for people's lives
especially for young people
and it's going to be really really
unfortunate and ugly in a few years
yeah all right so the book is really
spectacular and you dive into
what are considered some of the most
controversial topics of the day so we're
obviously going to get to all of that
but for
for anyone watching this that didn't see
our first uh interview
can you just do like a quick two-minute
sort of recap of your bio of how
of your training that led you to to
write this book
right so i when i was in my phd so i
have a phd in sexual neuroscience
research i now work as
a journalist i write predominantly about
the science of sex and gender
also about politics and how
politicization of scientific research is
really
doing society and a disservice and i
also write a lot about academic freedom
because that's becoming
another problem that we're seeing and so
for myself in the last few years of my
phd i had noticed that the political
climate
of academia was shifting and it was
becoming very clear that there are
certain topics that you are not allowed
to research that you're not allowed to
talk about or discuss
even if you are a scientific expert in
the field and
one topic in particular that i had been
following was
the issue of gender transition in
children
and so at that time every single
mainstream news piece pretty much i
could count on maybe
their one or two fingers the number of
pieces that had come out criticizing
this at that time
said that the best way forward for
children who are gender dysphoric so
they feel they're more like the opposite
sex
than the sex that they were born as the
best way forward for them was to
socially transition at a young age
younger being better and that once they
did transition they flourished you know
parents would say that they're doing so
much better
but from a scientific perspective all of
the research
literature suggests that it's actually
better for these children to wait
until they reach puberty there's a very
very high chance that they're going to
outgrow the way they feel
they're more likely to grow up to be gay
in adulthood and so i wrote an op-ed
about this
and i waited about six months because i
didn't know if i really wanted to
publish it because i knew it was going
to be there's going to be huge backlash
and i asked a number of my mentors and
colleagues what i should do and i
remember one of my mentors said to me
i asked him should i wait until i have
tenure because at the time i had planned
to stay in academia and i had a whole
plan in terms of what i was going to do
in terms of my research and
he said that tenure would not protect me
in this climate so
i decided to publish that piece and it
was
uh it was a difficult time i'm really
glad i did it and i write in the book
about you know what that process was
like for me and what it was like being
mobbed
really badly for the first time but once
you get through your first mobbing
you're
fine and you know they they can't stop
me now
yeah it's funny because uh you know i've
been through my own version of the mob
thing and i feel the same way
once you get through it you will survive
it's going to hurt it's going to suck
all of that stuff but once you get
through it and survive you will be
stronger on the other side
could you just talk a little bit though
about the reaction
from your colleagues because i'm still i
think a lot of people
can't accept somehow that academia could
be this corrupt that when you
write a paper using scientific evidence
saying
that you know when you transition this
young it doesn't necessarily
lead to a happier life and you use data
and evidence to support that
that you still get hit from the other
academics like i think people can't
really the average person who's not in
academia can't really understand
how that happened to academia
well i would say within sex research
which was my discipline
um it really has been like a canary in
the coal mine because we saw these
issues especially
left-leaning science denial this has
been an issue for decades in sexology
which is a scientific study of sex and
gender
so most of us in sexology are liberals i
consider myself still to be a liberal
and and i think my colleagues are just
focused on doing good work as they
should be
so i wouldn't say not that you were
saying this but i wouldn't say sex
research necessarily themselves
are corrupt in why they stay silent it's
more that
they know they already have a target on
their back usually sexologists are
dealing from
uh science now coming from the right
because usually not everyone on the
right is
is has an issue with sex researchers but
historically it's been more on the right
now that it's coming from the left it's
like sex researchers don't know how to
deal with it because
in a lot of cases it's people on the
same side as you and you're
you feel as though is this really as
important as calling it when the right
comes after us
so i think that's one layer of it you
know it's very competitive in academia
and to get a
10-year position is almost unheard of
nowadays so you're very busy
it's stressful and then then you have
these other academics in other
disciplines who are not scientific
not to say that they all have bad
intentions but they're starting to take
over they're the most vocal
and they're getting a lot of support
also i would say by mainstream news
outlets
so it as time goes on it feels i think
more and more
like you have more to lose than to gain
by speaking out so why start speaking
out now
and that's where that's how we got to
where we are so one of the things that
i'm i'm really amazed by and i've
brought this up with a couple
guests when i've talked about the trans
issue i've talked about this with
douglas murray and with rob smith and a
couple other people
is that in many ways the trans movement
now
seems almost perversely
anti-gay meaning that if you're an
effeminate young boy
they would rather see you transition
to be female rather than accept
that you actually are just a gay male so
i also think just for me personally it's
particularly weird because
i played with gi joes and transformers
so the so no one thought i was gay per
se
right but if i had but i have friends
that played that were boys that played
with barbies and people thought they
were gay when
when they were five and that if they now
even though they're maybe in their 40s
now if they
were growing up now and they were four
years old five years old doing that
they would have been put through
transition and that seems
sort of anti-gay doesn't it
100 100 and myself as we talked last
time i was with you
i grew up in the gay community i find
this very upsetting i have countless
friends who have reached out to me over
the years saying
you know deborah if i were growing up
now i probably would have transitioned
because this is such a common thing when
you are
a young child who is likely going to
grow up to be gay you tend to be
gender atypical and have interests that
are gender atypical and friends of the
opposite sex
so that's been a huge concern of mine
especially
we talked also about how transitioning
now i consider it and i think many in
the field would agree that it is
like the new conversion therapy where if
you have
a healthy gay child who say you have a
little boy who's very feminine
i think some parents have a sense
there's a chance he's going to grow up
to be gay
so if he's attracted to men when he's
older
if he transitions to female as a child
when he grows up he's going to be
appeared to be a straight woman so that
i mean
and i think homophobia does play a role
in terms of the parents who
not for all of them but for some of them
who are so on board with this and who
are championing this movement
and then there's another layer i think
of anti-gay sentiments in that
you have some individuals some trans
women not all
who are saying you know if i'm a woman
and i ha
i still have body parts that would be
considered male
if you are attracted to women you should
be wanting to have sex with me
and i don't think that's okay either i
think it's totally fine if people
are open to having i think trans people
do deserve
love and respect but i also don't think
it's right to
impose on people just like you know some
people might not be into asians with
blonde hair and
that's perfectly their right yeah do you
think it's starting
the sort of hysterical nature of this of
what you just described like you have to
be attracted to me if this and all of
those things
do you think it's starting to backfire
on them because i think most people
even even conservatives that sort of as
you alluded to earlier
they don't they don't sort of love
talking about these topics i don't know
a lot of conservatives that don't want
trans people
i don't know any conservatives actually
that don't want trans people to be
treated equally under the law or
something
or something like that but i do sense
that there is a real
backlash now where the movement has gone
so far
that people are just like you know what
forget this whole thing like the whole
thing is evil
and that's what i'm worried about
because when we group these letters
together
um i can i can sort of understand the
people that are frustrated like that
i could see that what where it really
concerns me is where we are going to be
going what the next
step is going to be in terms of what the
outcome is going to be and so we're
seeing also this growing trend of
non-binary people identifying as
non-binary and again that
can be for some people a way of coping
with the fact that they are gay or
lesbian
and they are not yet able to accept that
about themselves or because it is easier
to
not identify as gay in society because
there is still homophobia
and so can you just explain what
non-binary is just for
for someone that might not know yes so
it's people who
identify as a third gender so they may
say they're both genders or neither and
so non-binary gender fluid gender
neutral
gender queer even though queer is
considered for some people's to be a
slur
against gay people i don't tend to like
to use word queer
um so yeah so this is a really fast
quickly growing movement among
millennials
something like 10 identify as a third
gender so
that's a lot of people and i would be
totally on board people identifying
however they want if it didn't also
include
things like medical interventions like
double mastectomies
taking testosterone testosterone in a
lot of cases and in a lot of cases
i think these are just young gay people
who
are struggling with that and we should
offer them support
instead of having them undergo these
interventions
right so that's what i think is so
interesting about this because i think
the average person wants
most people to live and let live and
however you identify
that's fine as long as you're not you
know forcing someone to do something
i think what what happens then is this
next version where it's like
you can be you can say you're non-binary
and if you feel that way then
so be it but what happens is then they
won't let you accept
biology so now it seems like this is now
in
direct conflict with biology and i think
a lot of people are sort of
they're like no that's the last line
here that we're just not going to give
on
do you think that's fair to say right
and again i like you i have no issue
with people how they want to identify
just don't tell me that that's what the
scientific research
shows because when you start denying
science that doesn't help anyone
and the truth is eventually going to
come out so with regards to gender
gender is binary because for 99 of us
our gender is our biological sex of
course there are intersex people and
they're trans people for whom this
doesn't necessarily apply
but that's not to say that gender is a
spectrum
or that it's however you want it you
don't you don't
choose your gender you know this is what
they're teaching in education now that
that people
choose their gender and i think it's
really harmful to put all this
misinformation out there
especially in the case of someone who is
identifying this way for reasons
that may come from you know their own
internal struggles maybe they have other
mental health issues
and they're not we're not being able to
talk about that i think if we could have
the conversation and
someone could say yes i've considered
all these things
but i still feel i would like to have a
double mastectomy
and that would be better for me even
though a lot of these individuals are
really young when they're doing this
then i wouldn't have so much of a
problem but we can't even have the
conversation if you even try to bring it
up it's considered hateful even to say
that there are two genders is considered
transphobic now
right so what so all right
some people watching this are going to
clip it and show say that you're
transphobic and i'm a self-hating gay
and all all the usual stuff so to
counter that
and you write about this in the book can
you just sort of give me the the road
map if there was a young
person six years old that really felt
that you know they were
they were physically a boy but they
identified as a girl
what do you think a healthy road map
would be as opposed
to the unhealthy road map that you're
talking about that's just transitioning
them
at such a younger age i would say to
the parents especially just to love your
child unconditionally it doesn't matter
what toys they want to play with what
they want to drill how they want to
dress
who their friends are anything like that
let if this little boy wants to wear
makeup and dresses
and play with his girlfriends and that
should be totally fine and conversely if
you have a little boy who is male
typical
i think that's also fine i think among
especially woke
parents they don't want their children
to be gender typical nowadays which
is is just so bizarre so it's it's like
the inverse of what it used to be that
parents didn't want their kids playing
with gender atypical toys because
they're afraid their kids
are going to grow up to be gay and now
it's that they don't want them playing
with gender typical toys because they
think that's going to limit their growth
as
an adult so yeah just leave him alone
and if he says he wants to be the
opposite sex
see how he feels at puberty right so
then what what is what does that look
like so now okay so the child they
they love them they they let them play
with whatever they want be
friends with whatever they want to wear
whatever they want etc now now puberty
comes along
then then where are you at well
what would normally happen say in what's
been documented in the research
literature is
children who are gender dysphoric once
they start having crushes
on their peers once they start you know
growing into their bodies a lot of them
realize oh this is actually pretty great
i like my body
and i'm happy the ones who remain
dysphoric and
persist i would recommend seeing a
mental health professional or even even
prior to that point if if the child's
gender dysphoria is quite
severe and debilitating the issue though
is that nowadays
the vast vast majority of mental health
professionals who work with gender
dysphoric children
and even gender dysphoric adults are
i don't want to say that they're
compromised but definitely ideology is
playing a huge role in terms of how they
practice because
they cannot by law say
anything other than yes if you want to
transition i'll help you i'll help to
facilitate this because they're going to
be accused
of commit of practicing conversion
therapy even though conversion therapy
for gender identity does not exist
there's a difference between conversion
therapy for sexual orientation which as
we talked about last time is not
effective it should not be done there's
no such thing as conversion therapy for
gender identity because
young children who identify as the
opposite sex again
their gender is i don't use the word
fluid but
it's more flexible because they haven't
fully developed yet so with development
they're more likely to feel differently
right all right so wait just to
completely clear that up and we did go
into the first part or the second part
uh last time so gender or conversion
therapy for gay people meaning to take a
young gay boy
and to do whatever version of conversion
therapy there is
uh there's just no evidence that that
actually works what you're saying here
is
if uh if a therapist was dealing with a
young person who identified as the other
gender
that in essence they sort of have to
go with it because what what is it that
they would lose their license or
or is there because it's not conversion
at that point at some level right like
what what what are
or you think it's just the pressure of
being a therapist
that they'll they'll be ostracized it's
the climate it's that other
professionals will ostracize them it's
because they do run the risk of then
losing their license because
organizations will come after them and
say you are not practicing according to
what the standards are supposed to be
that you also have activists coming
after them trying to ruin their
reputation and their livelihood
and so what has happened is i know
colleagues who have told me that
anyone who does not feel right about
this they are
leaving the field they will not see
patients with gender dysphoria period
because they just they don't feel
right and they can't do their job
properly
yeah all right so i know you're a
neuroscientist first and you talk a lot
about the the brain
science behind some of this stuff can we
do like a like a sort of simple version
of what you know studying the brain
would show you about
say what a cisgendered heterosexual
brain might look like
versus uh you know the brain of a gay
person versus a trans person
right so there is a very strong research
literature documenting differences in
the brain associated with sexual
orientation so the
the uh gay people and straight people
when they're viewing
pornography of their choice that they
prefer so
if you have a straight man he'd be
looking at women if you have a gay man
who's looking at men
the same network of brain regions
activate in the brain so it has to do
with emotion has to do with the visual
system
has to do with regulating sexual drive
and so people often ask me about the
neuroimaging research
as it pertains to the transgender
population in terms of
is this something biological is this
something that we can see in the brain
because i think regardless of what your
political
affiliation is people are curious to
know is this something that
is hardwired it can be changed most
people
on the left i would say argue in favor
of biological or brain-based
explanations for gender dysphoria
because
in their minds that justifies
transitioning and i have to be clear i
do think that adults
should be supported in transitioning i
have no issue with that and research
does show that for adults transition can
be beneficial for them
so the issue i have is when people start
taking again the research and trying to
bend it to fit their political narrative
and so we had one study that came out i
think it was a year ago that was in
children with gender dysphoria so the
research literature to date
has been looking at gender dysphoria in
the brain has been in adults
and so what it has shown is that adults
with gender dysphoria their brains
are shifted in the direction of the sex
they identify as
as opposed to their sex at birth so if
you have a trans woman
so she's born male identifies as female
her brain has shifted in the direction
of
females but the thing is while these
studies is that they are conflated
with sexual orientation so again
everyone in the study
so if you have a trans woman she was
born male identifies as female she's
also attracted to
men so in all of these studies of trans
people they're they're attracted to
people who share their birth
sex so from a sexological perspective
because it can get a little bit
confusing
sexology we consider sexual orientation
for someone who's trans is based on
their birth sex
as opposed to how they they would be
post-transition
so all this to say is with the kids this
this study got so much media attention
people saying that gender dysphoria see
it's in the brain
because they they similarly showed that
their brains were shifted in the
direction of the sex they identify as
and this was
taken to be support for early
transitioning but again we don't know
the sexual orientation was not reported
so we don't know
maybe these children when they hit
puberty and get older
are going to be gay and again they don't
need to transition
so it's it's a really the sad thing is
that
researchers just don't want to touch
this now so what you will find is
all of the research coming out is
compromised because the only people that
are doing
this these studies are scientists who
are totally on board with gender
ideology
and they know that that they're not
going to have any issue when the studies
come out any studies that come out
criticizing gender ideology or
criticizing trans activism
are either going to get put under review
for a second time which is completely
ridiculous and unnecessary
or they're going to be retracted or the
scientist is going to be called names
and smeared so a lot of people just say
i'm going to pick something else
yeah well that's why i find what you do
so fascinating because it's like
sex is always controversial period in in
eternity in human history everything
about sex
is controversial and then when you
couple it with this new
woke ideology it's like i could i could
see why
someone like you would be worried you
know years ago about putting that paper
out or why the average
researcher now is just like i don't need
the headache and i'm not going to do it
you mentioned before that um that there
is evidence
that when adults transition that that
they are happier
on the other side is that is that
overwhelming or is that is it
50 50 or do you know
there was a meta-analysis that showed
that it can be beneficial but i think
what's important is that
it's taken on a case-by-case basis and
that each individual
is able to get the support they need and
to go through a proper
assessment with a mental health
professional to determine
is their gender dysphoria really about
gender and is this something that can be
solved
through transitioning because in a lot
of cases there are other issues going on
there was one study that showed for
people who present with gender dysphoria
as many as 60 have another psychiatric
mental condition and so that's something
that needs to be taken into
consideration but the thing is now
people don't even want to say that
gender dysphoria has anything to do with
the mind or
mental illness because mental illness is
stigmatized and i i don't think mental
illness or gender dysphoria
or transitioning should be stigmatized
but there's no way we're going to remove
the stigma
if we are not able to talk about it
openly
yeah you know i don't remember if this
happened to me before we last spoke on
the show
but i was at an event at university of
new hampshire and i was
talking about this topic and there was a
woman who said she was trans
and she was yelling that i'm a nazi and
i'm a racist and
all the usual stuff and i kept saying
listen i want you to be treated equally
under the law i hope you have someone
that loves you i want you to be able to
be employed and happy and have all the
benefits of everybody else
and she just kept saying you know i'm
off on all these things you're not going
to believe this or maybe you will
it turns out that she was a gender
studies professor
at the university i assume that's pretty
consistent with what you're hearing at
the university level too right not
not just the research level but just
even at just the university
the teaching level i find it's usually
people who are always advocating for
love and tolerance and acceptance
who are the most aggressive and nasty
when they disagree with you
and so that's not to say that all gender
scholars are like that definitely but
i do find i'm always amazed because
the whole purpose of being in academia
is about debating ideas
i would think that's the reason you
choose to be a professor is you want to
share ideas debate with your colleagues
it's about vigorously disagreeing
and that's how you get at the truth and
that's completely taken off the table
nowadays now it's about very much
there's only one way to think about an
issue and if you think outside of that
issue yes you're going to be called a
nazi
you're going to be de-platformed you're
going to be smeared publicly
and they're going to try and get you
fired so it's
it's really absurd but it's it's i think
it's not just in academia anymore as we
see everybody getting cancelled now this
has spread to the mainstream
yeah is it weird for you to be sort of
in a political fight because that's not
you know
sex is political now but like it's not
really what your passion is but you know
just from following you on twitter like
you're
you're you're in the political fight as
much as i am at this point
i i didn't ever think this is what i'd
be doing i really thought i would be a
scientist
i've always loved to write so i was
hoping to maybe write one day and do a
book one day and the fact that i've
gotten the chance to do
one now has just been such a blessing
and i feel so grateful
but for sure i feel it's something i
feel very strongly and i've always felt
very strongly about speaking
my mind and so i think it does make
sense in a way that this is
the direction i ended up going in
because i feel in this climate
you don't really have a choice either
you're going to put your head down and
stay quiet and just
you know it's not worth it or you're
gonna say you're gonna go through the
multiple mobbings and say
okay keep it coming then yeah um you
obviously talk in the book and you've
sort of mentioned it here about just the
denial
of what is actually presented in in the
research
have you figured out any tricks beyond
going on
podcasts and talking about this stuff on
youtube and everything else
to convince people that evidence
actually matters because in many ways
i think what the left is throwing at us
now is just sort of this
anti-intellectual set of ideas it's just
it does it doesn't matter like the more
evidence that you show
in a certain way it almost they use that
as proof that they are right because
you're part of the patriarchy or
you know you're part of the the machine
that they're trying to dismantle
have you figured out any tricks to to
actually break through in a way
i generally don't try to change the
minds of people who are
on either extreme or who are extremely
ideological because i feel at that point
it is
there are comparisons being made to
people who are extremely ideological
and people who are in a cult and i do
feel in some ways it's really difficult
to break through to someone especially
on the internet
unless you're sitting down with them
face to face maybe that can make a
difference but
i try to speak to the people who aren't
really sure what they think or they want
to learn more
and i always appreciate when people go
to the primary source so i mean i
i'm sure you know how this feels i get
accused of quote unquote saying things
all the time when i've never said
whatever it is the person is saying that
i said
this will be reported in newspapers this
will be all over social media
it's crazy to me i don't know how how
someone can do that and feel okay about
doing that
especially if you if this you know this
is something that
other people are going to see publicly
and i also think if they wanted to
actually
end issues like discrimination against
particular sexual and gender
minority groups that you would actually
want to go after people who are
saying hateful things if i'm just
reporting what the research says and you
have a problem with me
then let's talk about the research and
what your issues are with that and some
people do and i appreciate that and i
will engage with someone if it's in good
faith
but if you are making things up and
saying that i'm saying things i did not
say
how does that actually help your cause
and so it makes me feel like a lot of
people
in this fight don't really care about
the issues they say they care about they
care about clout
so i just generally and i would say to
your tour your audience
also um if you are engaging with people
and just trying to understand that's
that's totally great i think
it's you can only do so much
do you think the liberals have enough
juice
have enough energy have enough of a sort
of intellectual
undergirding to stand up to this woke
thing i think this is sort of the new
split
that you know the sort of 30 or 40 of us
you know that were loosely called the
intellectual dark web whatever it is now
um you know we were sort of warning
about all of this stuff and and i see a
real split
occurring at this point where there's
some of us that sort of think
that liberalism can somehow fight the
woke thing
even though i personally see no evidence
of it and then there's the ones that are
that are i think
more in line with my thinking on this
which is that there's a lot of bridges
to be built to the right it doesn't mean
that those guys are perfect all the time
and as you said you still identify as a
liberal as i do as well
but do you think that liberalism in and
of itself can withstand
what seems to be happening right now i
think so if more people start speaking
up and i do
see i'm actually surprised because some
of the people who said to me even two
years ago
i'm not going to get involved in this
this is not going to benefit me i don't
have a dog in this fight so you know
let's just hope it it
goes away on its own they are now saying
this is really bad
i didn't think it was going to get this
bad and i need to start speaking up
about this
how can i speak up about this what can i
do so i do think the tide is going to
turn i just think it's going to get
much worse before we get there and my
concern is also with all of the science
denial and all the denial of missing of
information how's that going to affect
our society and our
our knowledge and our growth you know
because
nothing good can come from denying
reality
yeah well we're in we're in a constant
denial of reality at this point
is you're in toronto right now is is
there any difference the way this is
discussed
maybe from a canadian perspective than
it is from an american perspective or
has the internet just
sort of level the playing field on that
i think
the biggest thing like what i tell
people i know is just to try to stay off
social media as much as you can because
that really exacerbates
everything it doesn't matter where in
the world you are i think social media
is really polarizing us
in terms of differences between
canadians and americans i think we're
just as
bad or we're getting there so don't
worry
you're not alone yeah we we export
everything so
the the title the end of gender i
thought was kind of interesting because
it's like
you're you're dealing with and unpacking
all of these seriously complex issues
related to identity and gender and
everything else
but you're calling it the end of gender
do you think that
what we're left with at the end of this
conversation if we can
truly have it honestly is that gender
won't matter won't exist what do you
mean by the end
yeah let me clarify because when i
announced this when i
announced the book on social media
people got upset at me because they
thought i was saying that this
is like the very super woke far left
right end of gender and that gender
doesn't exist anymore or that
gender is completely what you want it to
be and it's based in self-identification
and there's no tethering to biology or
objectivity
and that's not at all what i'm saying
and i really want to emphasize i'm
asking you
that's why opposite of that i'm saying
gender is very much
biologically based and it is
the misinformation and denial of science
and denial of biology and denial of
evolutionary psychology
that is leading us to not have a proper
understanding of gender
and that's why i see its demise yeah
so so paint the picture that turns some
of this around besides just some people
getting braver like the political part
of this even i mean when you see
at this point all of these you know the
lgbt
organizations uh that at this point i
think are just basically using gay
people to now push the gender stuff
i mean what what has to happen to them
are are there non-profits that are
fighting this
from a correct scientific perspective
like what has to happen now really
what i see happening and i actually have
a line in the book where i say i'm
appalled
and i love i love the gay community and
i have many gay men who've reached out
to me over the years complete strangers
who say to me thank you for saying what
you did
because i was one of these children i
actually had one individual reach out to
me tell me around this around the time
my first op-ed came out he said i was
thinking of transitioning
and i read your op-ed and i decided to
wait and i'm so glad i did
so there is a line in the book where i
say i'm appalled at the number of gay
men who are
in support of transitioning children
because this is leading to the
extermination of gay kids
and what i really think is going to
happen and this is so unfortunate it
makes me so sad is that these kids are
going to be
changing their minds in a few years i
say five to ten years
so where what is this this is going to
be august 2020 when this comes out so
give it five to ten years they're gonna
be so many kids who are saying
why did my parents let me do this why
did mental health why did medical
professionals let me do this
they are going to have issues from being
on hormonal treatments from surgery
i'm already seeing all of these young
people these d transitioners and it
really breaks my heart and no one is
listening to them and no one is taking
them seriously
and it's there are going to be tons of
class action lawsuits and
i already see good clinicians in the
field who are concerned
because they know it's coming and and
they feel at a loss
because we've been trying to raise
attention and get people to take us
seriously but they just call us
transphobic
right and by the way it's not just the
personal issues and the medical issues
and everything else there's gonna be an
insane amount of legal issues that pop
up there i think there's gonna be kids
you know they'll be young adults at the
time that are going to start suing their
parents i think they're going to start
suing
the doctors and probably everybody else
involved i'm sure there are lawyers
looking at that right now there's got to
be right and i would say to your
audience too because i'm sure
they've been following these issues as
well pay attention to the people who are
most loudly and proudly embracing this
and saying this is great for the kids
because when this time comes they're
going to turn around and say
we had no idea this was going to happen
and they're going to pretend that that
they had no idea when they are coming
after those of us who are speaking out
about it
i know it's a little weird to be ahead
of the curve isn't it because you kind
of feel like you're behind it sometimes
as as the things start to come true it
feels
the odd thing and when i was writing
this book i felt the whole time it was a
very emotional process for me because it
felt very much like
those of us who see it it's like we're
able to see the future and we're just
trying to scream as loud as possible to
get people to pay attention
don't i know it i know it uh you just
mentioned the deep the detransitioning
part of this is there uh a lot of
literature is there or a lot of research
on that as far as how many people
have done it are they happier after are
they
suicidal after i mean what do the
numbers look like on that
there was one study in sweden that
looked at people who had
transitioned and then trans so changed
the the
marker on their legal documentation and
then changed it back
they found that about two percent of
people who had transitioned
changed back but the thing is not
everyone who detransitions does it
legally
and also the data collected for that
study uh it finished around
2011 i think it was so that was before
this huge
influx we see of young people especially
young women identifying
as male and i've written quite a bit and
in the book i talk about rapid onset
gender dysphoria which is this
phenomenon of young women who are
very quickly identifying as male wanting
to transition to male taking
testosterone again getting double
mastectomy
um when they are very gender typical as
children it's usually very
out of the blue usually they have other
mental health issues like
autism for a lot of them they have
sexual trauma that's not being talked
about
and so we don't yet have the data for
that we don't know what that's going to
look like although there is one
county in the uk where hundreds of
d transitioners are coming out and
saying i'm i have autism
i'm lesbian and why didn't people
why didn't why didn't professionals you
know do what
they should have done which is ask me
questions
yeah i can't imagine discussing anything
almost more controversial than that you
couple this sort of rapid transition
with
autism and then you get you know people
to try to talk about that it's like
no one's gonna you could see why the
average uh researcher just would just be
like no way i'm not doing this
no and it's difficult enough to get a
study published you know to get
funding for your i mean the book i talk
about a number of situations where
researchers have gotten approval and
they've got money to do their study and
still
they have to deal with all these extra
roadblocks that pop up or people coming
after them and threatening them
so at the end of the day you know the
science is taking a very unfortunate
turn i think we're going to look back on
this period
with with a lot of horror and
disappointment but
i'm hoping that the the outcome is not
going to be
that terrible if we start speaking out
about it yeah
have they done real research on the the
social pressures
related to all of this so like when you
mention the rapid onset where suddenly a
whole bunch of girls
that otherwise like it sort of appears
out of nowhere in essence
um that could it be from a peer group
and then they're really doing these
things that are just
really just crazily extreme to fit in
in essence yeah so this the one study
that's been done on rapid onset gender
dysphoria to date
uh was published in 2018 by lisa litman
and she did
the research did suggest that there's a
pure contagion aspect to it
in that these girls so for 40 of the
girls in the study who
had come out as trans very quickly they
had at least
half of their their friend group also
identified as transgender
which is 70 times the rate of what you
would see in the general population
in terms of people who identify as
transgender so that
in itself should raise a red flag in
most people's minds
but people are saying oh this is due to
greater social acceptance but if that's
the case why is it you don't see the
same thing among boys
you don't see the same thing among
people of different ages it's very
specific to
teenage girls and young adults young
women yeah
so what do you make of that because boy
because young boys you know young boys
can be susceptible to
to peer pressure and all that kind of
stuff too so what what is that about
then
i think for these young women in
particular from the conversations i've
had with them it's very much about
being discomf feeling discomfort with
their body for a lot of them
going through puberty and suddenly
getting male attention and not really
appreciating attention from certain
people and and also that
the messages that they're getting from
the media is that if you are gender
non-conforming at all as a woman
then you are probably transgender or you
are probably another gender and if you
look at celebrities a lot of
celebrities who are born female who are
gender atypical identify as a third
gender
so i think no one is saying to them it's
okay if you
are a young woman and you are different
or you feel like you don't fit in
it's okay that's normal another thing is
a lot of young women are being told if
they don't like getting a period
that that means that that they should be
a man and i'm thinking
no woman likes getting her period that's
just part of being a woman and it's
me i love being a woman you know i take
a lot of pride in being a woman
so i i just wish that we could have this
conversation or there's more of this
happening
because they are not they're not
receiving this information they're only
receiving one message
yeah so i'm going to sort of give you a
theory that i've been
trying to put together through some of
my own interactions so this is not
scientific in any way but i think
there's probably something to it
that when what i find on twitter is the
the angriest and most hostile
and and awful saying the worst things
possible to me if whenever that happens
from you know
one of these anonymous accounts i go to
the account and almost without exception
they have their gender profile uh their
pronouns in there he him she her z
you know the whole thing and i do think
there's a sort of connection
between um i want to be very clean about
what i'm saying here that there's sort
of a connection between
knowing who you are and knowing reality
as it is and then
being happy or functional or something
can can you clean this one up for me
because i haven't fully pieced it
together
but i do think it's quite bizarre that
the people who are constantly preaching
about tolerance
and diversity and everything else are
are in many cases the ones that act
completely the reverse of that
i think part of that could be because
gender is so trendy nowadays and it's
because people are given attention and
praise
for identifying in a way that is
different from male and female i think
for some people
and this is not to say that everyone who
identifies
as something other than male or female
or anyone who is doesn't identify as
their birth sex
has mental psychopathology but i do
think for some people who have
pre-existing psychopathology they're
latching on to gender and this movement
as a way to bring about meaning in their
life or as a way of
feeling good about themselves and so
anyone who questions that
it they take that very very personally
and very deeply and i think that's part
of why they lash out in such a horrible
way
yeah what do you make of the the
intersectional
piece of this whole thing that even
related to everything going on right now
with um the protests and the riots and
black lives matter
you know we had your initial black lives
matter movement and then
about 10 days in there was this massive
rally i think it was in brooklyn
for black trans lives and i never heard
anyone that's
you know that had a problem with black
trans people i mean the the these things
have all become
something that's not quite what they are
can you explain sort of the
intersectional piece of this
how they all i'm not linked together i'm
not a fan of
intersectionality as you probably know
so i just see it as a way for people to
further promote their own personal
agenda i have nothing against
wanting to protest for trans lives or
black trans lives
or anyone's life or black lives i'm all
for it
but it's when you start be authority
being authoritarian and
starting to shut down scientists right
they had
they had a day where they this was not
about black trans lives but they shut
down
stem for a day in the name of fighting
racism
which makes absolutely no sense to me so
i think
like identity politics it's just about
in creating increasingly smaller
factions
to further divide us and for particular
people to get their chance at having
some power
are you worried that because we're
injecting
race into every conversation we're
injecting gender into every conversation
and sexuality and all of these things
into
everything and now it's in sports and
messages or just
everywhere every tv show that you watch
that we're gonna sort of
raise a generation of bigots not because
they're actually bigoted
but they'll just be sick of all of these
issues and then they're going to view
the world
through that lens where everything is
about your race and your gender and your
sexuality and everything else
yeah that definitely concerns me because
for me and maybe i have an old
school view of things but to me to
assume that the way someone looks or
that their race
says anything about the kind of person
they are or the way they think or their
capabilities
that to me is racist but i find that in
woke land it's racist to assume that
someone's race doesn't play in those
things and i'll never forget i remember
very early on when i started writing i
went to this
event and i spoke with one of the
organizers and
she said to me she looked at my eyes and
she said i think it's great that you
write
we need more women who look like you
writing
and i thought to me that sounds a bit
racist but then i realized after
that what she she thought this was a
good thing like that she was praising me
because she's saying you know
i guess there aren't many asian women
who are journalists but
i don't want to be considered a good
journalist
because i'm asian or because i'm a woman
i want it to be because my work is good
and i think that's what
it should be about your value as a human
being should be about who you are as a
person
not ticking off certain boxes so it does
disturb me quite a bit because i feel
especially for white people they feel
like they can't
speak up about it because they're going
to get called racist
yeah but deborah you know that asians
are the new white people right i mean we
now know
i mean we know this right like by the
woke ideology asian people are now in
effect white
because asian people regardless of the
ethnicity or nationality in most cases
have succeeded so now we just gotta
throw them in with the white people when
i saw that pamphlet that was circulating
a couple
weeks ago and it was something like hard
work is whiteness
i just thought okay i guess we are white
then
yeah well you're right you're talking
about the thing that was put out by the
uh was it at the black museum in dc
the african-american museum in dc i
think they pronounce everybody
so much yeah there's so many of them but
in effect if you believe in the
individual and you believe in hard work
and you believe in family that these are
all tools of white supremacy
any i thought anyone could work hard or
you know care about the nuclear family
or anything else
um what else should we what else should
we hit on here how about that for an
open question
what else what are the other things that
you you're hitting on in the book that
you think the average person needs to
know about
well what i can do is i can maybe just
summarize what the different myths are
because that will give
your audience a sense of what we cover
so i took a science-based approach
to debunking some of the most prominent
myths in our society so there are nine
of them
so i talk about how biological sex and
gender are both
not social constructs they are not
spectrums
i talk about how sexual orientation is
related to gender identity even though
many activists and many even educational
organizations say they're unrelated
that's not true they are related
i talk about gender transitioning in
children
i talk about uh the issue of
trans women in women's spaces and sports
and prisons
um and then i talk about sex differences
let's stop on that
let's stop on that one for a sec because
i because i'm i'm amazed by this i mean
this thing
where we're watching uh males
transition to female and then play
in women's sports and break every record
in weightlifting and racing and all of
these other things
and it's like man one day there's going
to be a washed up nba player
who is going to transition to female and
be the mvp in the wnba and then what are
the feminists going to say
but i believe that will happen in the
next couple years
what will the feminists say at this
point i think it depends on what kind of
feminist
so liberal feminists will say probably
say
what's the problem i i don't think most
athletes
who are identifying as female
or coming out as female are necessarily
doing it to get an advantage
but it's not to say that it's never
going to happen and
uh but whereas radical feminists who are
critical of gender and are critical of
this whole thing they've been the most
outspoken about this and i would still i
mean i
i identified as a feminist up until a
couple years ago i still want gender
equality for men and women i think we do
for the most part have that
but feminism i've been critical of
feminism just because i think it has
lost sight of its main goals and uh so
radical feminists
you know have joined hands with
conservatives which would have been
completely
unprecedented to say this this is not
fair
and to consider again i i think i have
no issue referring to a trans woman as
she you know referring to her using the
pronouns she'd like and give her respect
and
and legal protections but in something
like sports or say mixed martial arts
which is one of my favorite sports
you cannot pretend that there are no
differences at all between trans women
even after transitioning and women who
are born women because someone can get
very badly hurt or even killed
in a fight is the irony then that i
guess the radical feminists
would would they argue that there should
just be no women
sports at that point if if gender is
just a social construct i mean
wouldn't they just say okay well then
there shouldn't be any women's sports
but then unfortunately what they would
what they would end up with is that
there would be no women in sports or or
very few women in sports
wouldn't that be the end outcome
my said so i again i'm not a radical
feminist so i don't want to speak for
the community but my sense would be
because they don't deny biological sex
being real so they would say women
deserve to have equal opportunities and
trans women are
they don't consider trans women to be
women because they were born male and
they've been
in their eyes socialized as men so
there's no way that they can
understand what it's like to be a woman
but
from my understanding radical feminists
are in favor of sex segregation in terms
of sports because that's the only way
that women have a fair
choice chance it's not that women are
less capable it's just that's
the reality with biology and
reality yeah and reality well speaking
of reality did you see the
the video uh joe biden was at the lgbt
equality forum and he said that
it's not what prison it's not what
gender
your uh your birth certificate says that
should decide what prison you go to
it's what gender you identify as meaning
that
you could just say okay i'm a woman you
could be a male murderer
say i identify as woman and then they'll
put you in a female prison i mean stuff
like that must make your head explode
well i did see that i remember thinking
i wish that they had someone who worked
with forensic populations to speak to
this because that is not
that's definitely not a good idea and i
have worked with sex offenders in the
past
both in a research and clinical capacity
and
we used to have a saying how do you know
a sex offender is lying
his lips are moving so i think as with
anything in these issues they have to be
on a case-by-case basis but
you know i detail in the book a little
bit more about what i specifically think
should be done and how we should
approach these issues but it's just
you know it's really become a question
of are you on the left or right and you
and people basically state what they
think their side
wants them to say on these issues yeah
are there any other myths we should hit
on
um in the book oh so the last few are
sex differences in sex and dating
because there's so much misinformation
young people are totally confused and
have no idea how to go about
dating nowadays so i offer some advice i
talk about gender gender-neutral
parenting
and then also social justice and in
academia and i have to say so i
announced this book as of today what
we're taping
i announced it only a couple days ago um
one of one very prominent columnist in
canada barbara k
she wrote a review about my book and
the publication so she'd been at the
national post for 20 years they refused
to
run her review because it was a positive
review
and so she subsequently resigned and
this is after a number of
i think this was the the straw that
broke the camel's back but
i'm just amazed at already there's
there's a lot of
pushback to this book and it's just
science why is that
why is that seen as threatening this is
something i just cannot grasp i
understand why people see it as
threatening but we need to talk about
why and at the end of the day scientists
need to be able to do their job
yeah barbara k you know she's one of the
i know you know this i mean she's one of
the great
journalists of canada i actually saw the
tweet about her resignation i had no i i
didn't click it
uh you know i was doing a couple other
things i had no idea it had to do with
your book that that is
unbelievable absolutely well
unbelievable everything's unbelievable
now so i guess it's totally believable
she did a long facebook post explaining
why she was leaving and then the other
half of it was
the review of my book and then so both
of those pieces were
run by the post millennials so if your
audience wants to look into that a bit
more they can check that out
yeah absolutely well deborah good luck
with the book uh we're going to put the
link to the end of gender
right down below and i hope we can do
this in person
at some point or i'll come to toronto or
you'll come here
we'll figure something out yeah
yeah it's great to see you too if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about academia instead of
non-stop yelling check out our academia
playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell